>> Quick, this woman needs a blood transfusion.
>> Why what happened?
>> She was in a car accident and she's lost a lot of
blood and she may not survive if she doesn't get a transfusion soon.
>> Oh, okay, well what's her blood type?
>> Well we don't know, we need find out.
>> Knowing a person's blood type can
be really important. If you give somebody the
wrong blood type their immune system can
mount a response and actually cause you harm.
>> So how does the body know it's the wrong blood type?
>> Well, your immune system does a really good job at recognizing
self versus non self, and it does this because when you're growing up
it knows the blood type that you're growing up with
because that's what it's exposed to. And so when it
sees a blood type that it doesn't recognize it knows
it doesn't belong there and it tries to attack it.
>> Sounds really important, no wonder there's so many tests
you can take to tell what your blood type is.
>> Right in the clinic that's very true, but
what's really cool is your genome reveals the same
information. In this lesson we're going to discover how your
genome uses its code to create your blood type. Also,
here's an incomplete concept map for lesson three that you can also download
from the instructor's notes. As usual, print it out or just keep it
handy and see if you can fill in the empty blanks as you
go through the lesson. Now if you prefer to have the complete version just
skip to the end and look in the instructor's notes for the complete
concept map. However, I highly encourage
you to try using this incomplete version
now, filling in your own notes as the lesson progresses and then we'll
check your progress out on the completed map at the end of the lesson.